the question that me and my co-founder
max maxtel
asked ourselves was um what type of life
do we want to live
right and for us the answer is we just
want to spend time
learning and creating right
[Music]
valentine perez thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you
thank you michael i'm doing great um how
about you
i'm doing fantastic thank you so much
for for joining me being so generous
with your time
you're calling from los angeles and
you're actually
living with a cliff weitzman who i
believe was
one of the first guests on the show
which is pretty pretty cool
amazing yeah so super close friend
from mexico i went to brown university
co-president of the entrepreneurship
program there
got into startups worked in quite a few
places
and one of them is an inter software
engineering intern at snapchat which i'd
love to hear
and what that experience was all about
but now most recently you are
the ceo and co-founder of monthly an
online education platform and focusing
on
month courses right is it did i get that
right
yeah the co-founder co-founder of
monthly and
we do one month hands-on online classes
yeah
taught by big creators and artists
amazing amazing so you know valentin
before we get into really the depth of
monthly and what you're doing there i'd
love to go back a little bit
and talk about your entrepreneurial
journey and sort of the the steps
leading up to
uh to your endeavor right now so when
would you consider you started
as an entrepreneur oh
um i would say since like since ever
since i can remember
i was just always with the
entrepreneurial mindset
and i think it's because of the way that
i grew up
and the way that um my parents raised me
like one of the earliest questions that
i always remember my dad asking myself
is
would you rather be the
tail of a lion or the head of a mouse
um and i would always ironically answer
the head of a lion
but for him he was always like asking
that question
kind of rhetorically that it's better to
be
the head of a mouse even it's a small
thing you be
the entrepreneur the person like leading
or having your own like charge of your
own destiny
than destiny than being the tale of a
bigger organization
or you know some other group so
ever since i was a kid i was always
working on
projects um selling things like building
stuff
like you know websites apps robots um
like selling sushi across my
neighborhood like everything that you
can imagine
um and yeah
and it just continues
sorry what was the motivation for doing
all those projects was it
simply to to make money where some
people sell lemonade in a lemonade stand
you did
other entrepreneurial projects or was it
or or was there other
other reasons why you went about them
yeah i mean i think when i was a kid it
was mostly
fun right it's just like i was just
having fun playing around
um that's what i found fun fulfilling
and then it was also about like then
started getting into creating value
and helping other people right so um i
see entrepreneur entrepreneurship is
just
literally the way it's like you're
creating value
right and you're helping improve other
people's lives
and then i think so i think there's like
you know
fun play creating value but a big part
of it for me too is curiosity
and like learning new things and
understanding
new parts of the world and like as i'm
experimenting um
i think those that and then like i think
some other
motivators for me are
love just coming like
giving love receiving love um
uh gratefulness always being grateful
about what i have and
making the most out of the opportunities
and chances that i have
um and yeah i think the creating value
goes with the desire to be useful
um which yeah it's just creating value
love gratefulness curiosity play fun
yeah
right so you're talking about creating
value
love curiosity if i recall correctly one
of the things that you also
did is send a newsletter with a bunch of
gifts
right talk to me a little bit about that
newsletter
yeah so um
one thing i love doing is
curating things so ever since i was a
kid i had a list
of my favorite quotes or like a list of
my favorite
articles like and i always just stored
all these things and i love finding the
gems in the internet of like what are
the best
videos what are the best articles what
are the best ideas or the best books
um and i just like have a lot of fun
doing this
and then you know part of that is like i
also
like joined a lot of newsletters like i
spent a lot of time just learning
things online and like you know part of
that was newsletters
and then i thought like you know i'm
like storing all these things
um doing it myself why don't i just
share all this that i've accumulated all
this
amazing gems articles ideas
um habits etc and just share them with
my friends and family so i just
you know as an experiment i posted like
hey would everyone be interested
and got like hundreds of messages and
comments
of people that wanted to like get this
newsletter um and
i just started sending in and the the
premise was
you know mouth-watering articles
um like juice books yeah it's like
provoke thought pro-looking pictures so
it wasn't
uh it was like across like many
different types of media all of them
um the best things that i can find and
it wasn't
only um things that i found throughout
the week
it was like over the years and the whole
lifetime of like
creating all these things right so i
focused on
quality over recency right and i did
sprinkle a bit of efficiency because
you know part of my newsletter was also
sending my favorite like songs and new
artists that i was finding
so i also like just love making spotify
playlists for example um
and and yeah that was like part of a
part of the newsletter and and it
actually was
extremely fun and and rewarding because
it was a way to
keep in touch with a ton of friends and
family and people
right by i only have to write this email
once and send it once a week and it gets
to like
hundreds of people and then like a lot
of anyone if they're interested they can
reply or not
um but i always had like people sharing
back
more thoughts more ideas like just
having a conversation it was just
absolute blast um i think that's it
that's
there's so much ingenuity in that i i
took inspiration from
a great friend of mine drew bent i don't
know if you got to meet him but he's a
knight hennessy scholar at stanford and
he went to mit launch with me
and he sent out this year in review
drew's year in review
as in as a one-time once a year
newsletter and i started adopting
that doing it more quarterly or or
biannually
and it was amazing to see how with one
email i can reach hundreds of people and
all of a sudden you get the responses
and you're re
you're invigorating these connections
and i think that
it's such a wonderful technique to get
in touch with people i'm obviously
enjoying
meeting new people and and maintaining
relationships through
a show like this so i'm definitely in
favor of all of these different
endeavors
talk to me a little bit about
entrepreneurship at brown
you're at university what does it mean
to be
an american college student in america
right you're from mexico but you're
studying college in america and you're
you're you're leading an
entrepreneurship experience
also for other students what was that
about
yeah so for me i just i knew that i
wanted to get involved with
entrepreneurship
scene even before getting to brown once
i got to brown like that was like the
first thing that i
did um like i joined the hackathon
and hackathon organizing team because i
went to the hackathon as a high schooler
uh before brown and so i knew i wanted
to be a part of that
and when i got to brown like i knew that
i wanted to continue working on my own
entrepreneurial projects
um but i also i saw super valuable
as like you know meeting all the other
entrepreneurs all the people
interested in making things right so
what better way than by taking the lead
in the entrepreneurship club
and finding these people cultivating
these people and cultivating an
environment that would be the best place
for entrepreneurship
like that was my my goal i just want to
make brown and a college hill that has
brown and risty the the rhode island
school design
as the best place for entrepreneurship
and
um yeah it was like a ton of fun um
i like founded four different
conferences there
um did like founded like a speaker
series like trips to san francisco new
york to visit alumni like
so many different things like um i think
was it like
10x the the group size
like double the budget of the
entrepreneurship club uh
engaged an alumni group um so we had
like an
alumni presence uh interviewed
uh a new and found a new direct like
help find
a new director for the news now so
center for entrepreneurship
help um you know think about like the
space and etc so
i was super involved in that and it was
an
absolutely super fulfilling experience
and an amazing learning experience
because i saw it as a platform
to practice entrepreneurship right and
it was just
amazing a platform to practice
entrepreneurship i think it
reminds me obviously of the program we
both did mit launch
and it's all about practicing
entrepreneurship it's
it's taking a sandbox that you can't
really destroy anything
because the worst thing that could
possibly happen is that you'll say
okay i tried i failed by the way i'm
still in high school
college and i it's not like i have a
children to feed
or or family to take care of and i'll
move on and take the lessons i learned
so how did that lead up now to monthly
and and
what are you trying to do with education
space
yeah so with monthly um what we're doing
is
we're revolutionizing how people learn
online
so like this comes from
like as a kid like always my favorite
thing is learning right learning and
creating things
so the question i was working on
startups working on projects
um and then you know i realized that i
could be working on anything
right like um you know i had the
resources i had the skills
so the question that me and my
co-founder max
maxtosh asked ourselves was um what type
of life do we want to live
right and for us the answer is we just
want to spend time
learning and creating right like that's
what we love and
so how can we build a system that allows
us to live this life
and allow other people to live this life
as well right so
for us it was like okay how do we build
the learning platform of our dreams and
who do we want to learn from
how do we make it a sociable like
amazing experience
how do you make it so that you finish
with tangible projects
so for our classes for example all our
classes you finish with something
tangible so in your music production
class
you finish with three songs that you
have created by the end wow in our paper
class
you finish with a realistic portrait or
like a painting that is
um inspired by your imagination right
and your background
uh you can feel you can finish with a
film
etc and so these classes
they're different from the normal online
classes
normal classes usually they might be
just you know a playlist of videos right
that you watch
but our classes you know they have a
specific start date and an ending right
all of them are one month
hence the name monthly and throughout
the experience
you're put into a peer group of 20 other
students from around the world
right so you know you can you can invite
friends to be in the cmp group
but you're in the social experience
where you know you will see what other
people are working on you can give
feedback
you receive feedback you see um you know
you get inspired
you make new friends and you know this
peer group also came from you know at
brown
um i started a group called junto where
every saturday
um we would meet at my at my house in
the living room
um and we'll just talk about life um and
like
you know things that we were learning
and it was just such an
intimate amazing environment um
and i wanted to replicate that you know
within monthly so hence like
you know instead of seeing a class that
you have like 2 000 students and
you don't like really connect with
anyone you know we split into peer
groups so you can connect with the 20
peers that you're learning with
right and by the end of the month you
know you're getting feedback you the
the creator the instructor is also
interacting with the students and then
you
you all finish with something that you
share right so everyone finishes with
something that i can't help but share
with all the friends family social media
and then that just brings in a lot more
people in um
that that's amazing so just to
understand a little bit better
the context of where monthly
where where the market that monthly is
in so
are these mainly for for young
adults or kids that want to acquire a
new skill
a specialized skill that you then
provide
a month-long course that is very
intimate
intensive and then by the end of which
they finish with a
tangible product is that what you're
doing
um yes uh we
our audience is actually you know we've
seen people that are
you know eight-year-olds to
seven-year-olds 17 year olds like it's
like a huge range of
like everyone is interested because our
classes are you know singing music
production
are like um even like creative
engineering and
et cetera like we have like a big range
of of topics
but you're right that the main
demographic is
you know young adults um mostly
uh you know they might want to like
improve their skill
um but also a lot of the times
they're just you know they're in their
corporate job and they like want to do
something
more with their life they want to do
something creative they want to do
something cool they want to do something
exciting
or they want to be a part of a community
and this is like you know what we're
providing to people and we see that
you know it's it's transforming people's
lives people
you know finish the class and they're
like wow
this has been the most productive 30
days of my life or
i've learned more in this past month and
the past 10 years trying to learn to
make music and
these are quotes from video testimonials
at this point we have
thousands of video testimonials people
who went out of the way
to record themselves of how much they
love their experience and post it to
youtube
um and and like it's just been
super inspirational to see and like to
see what people are creating the
connection that they're making
um and you know it's crazy to see that
our completion rates for people to
finish their classes are
10x what uh industry averages for our
online platforms so yeah i think
what do you think that is what what is
that
yeah i think it's a combination of
factors right so
one um these classes
you see the end like you see what you're
working towards
right like we frame the classes like you
know this is positive production class
you're gonna finish with three songs
right and everything in the curriculum
is structured
to help you achieve that right and like
get to that point
right so um you know all the videos like
the projects the feedback sessions um
and they all build
progressively towards the final projects
right so that's one thing
the other thing is the social aspect
right you're in a peer group where you
see that
other people are like submitting the
projects like watching the video so like
monkey see monkey do right like um
humans are like if they see other people
doing this like they don't want to like
let them down even though
you know they may be strangers but like
they're in your peer group
either like you're gonna get a sign for
feedback right so it also helps people
you know there's deadlines so that and
and the deadlines are not just
arbitrary they're actually in this case
they're useful because
if you submit in time the next day
you're going to get feedback if not
you may not get right because you didn't
submit so that
then obviously um the classes are framed
as like
a commitment so it's not just um
you know maybe i'll just like pay for
some like subscription service that like
maybe
i'll like get to this later like which
usually never happens it's like
you know a month that you're going to
commit and there's a start date and the
finished dates mentally people are
prepared for that
um and the the prices are also high
right so
you know there's various reasons why we
wanted to place price at prices high
one of them is for the commitment right
like we want people to actually commit
and
follow through and finish the classes so
the classes are priced
around usually 279 dollars um
so you know people like serious about it
and like you know
they enroll and they go for it um i
think
those are some of the things that's just
saying i think that's that's super super
cool
yeah yeah and like that the instructors
that we get like
there's are always you know big name
people are already have big audiences
are very charismatic in the way that
they teach
um so like people are always engaged the
curriculum that we design is like
very much like we spend a lot of time
being very meticulous about how we
design a very effective
engaging curriculum so that also helps i
think it's just like
such a big combination of things well
what surprised you the most
out of the journey or even more
interesting than that what what
lessons did you take with you from your
prior entrepreneurial experiences
that you're saying like wow i'm so glad
that i had these experiences at brown
and mit launch and
and as a kid that now at the start of
you saying ah
i've seen this i've experienced this
this is how i want to tackle this
yeah i mean great question i think
there's just endless
uh things and ideas that
you can you can learn from even like
from mistakes from
successes or anything i think you can
learn um
i think
are you looking for like specific like
nuggets of advice or like a specific
experience
that happened like i'd love to know
what how you see your prior
entrepreneurial experience
folding into or molding into monthly
because a lot of people are saying
yeah i'll defer entrepreneurship to when
i'm good and ready i'll accumulate
you know professional experiences and
then i'll be an entrepreneur and
here you have an example of somebody
who's been an entrepreneur their whole
life
leading up to this moment oh yeah well i
mean i think i think it's it's
it's there like i just i see it
anything that comes up you know with
monthly
like has come up like most cases like
before
or even if they if it hasn't come up
right you have the muscle and the
exercise
of being able to figure new things out
right and like
a lot of it is like pattern recognition
right and like a lot of patterns even
though they might be like a little
slightly different
it's like slightly similar to other
things that you have done before
right so that exercise and practice of
entrepreneurship i think is like
extremely valuable and fun and
rewarding and everything that you want
right and useful for later and like
i just see it like everywhere like you
know um
one thing is with um
you know working with a team right and
like leading people right like i think
that was
huge when i was a a leader like
co-president of
at brown ap um others like
you know how do you figure out like how
do you code an app
and what needs to get built right like
you know for all the apps that i
launched i had
um you know before monthly and during my
time at browning before brown
i think i had seven apps in the app
store so i was like wow they're familiar
with
with the launch process um and then
you know other like learning experiences
was like you know i built something
really cool
but then you know i realized that even
though the thing was really cool
it's not gonna get to anyone's hands if
there's no distribution
right so you know learning about
distribution learning about like
you know talking to users and reading
between the lines i think a lot of times
you know
you may ask a question people may say
something but they're really meaning
something else or they have a deeper
like desire that they're trying to
satisfy so it's a lot about
like that building up that intuition to
being able to
identify these things
um the classic i love it
quote of um you know if you would ask
what people wanted they would have said
faster horses
right so right right a hundred percent
volunteering i i'm sad that we only have
20 minutes for this show
but but thank you for being so generous
with your time before we finish
uh what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
good question um one
um i'd say understander i love to
understand things it's like my favorite
thing you know with learning
the thing that i like is understanding
things so understanding you know part
like about the world about myself
about people about concepts everything i
just love understanding
that um second one is
the farinker and this is like made up
word
um you guys basically i just made it up
it means like
different thinker right like i love to
think differently i like
love to just go up the beaten path like
come up with
new words new ideas new ways of doing
things
um and that's something that represents
that and then
the third one is um would be
slopi is also a made-up word um
which means that i love focusing on
slope
more than a y-intercept and this comes
from a quote that i love is uh
a little bit of a little bit of slope
makes up for a lot of y-intercept
right so y intercept is
or you may be right and um
that like if you see two lines like i
may not like have it
be able to draw this but what matters
most is the slope right even if you
start it there's a line that started up
here
the slope is like this but you started
down here and the slope is like this
it'll cross it
like in short amount of time right so
i think as long as you're focusing on
growth and learning
then you can get to you know 100 and i
think
it's it's even more relevant when you're
thinking people often say that
look somebody else is already doing this
or somebody else is is
starting off at a different stage than i
am and it's not about the stage you're
starting off it's a marathon it's not a
sprint it's about how
it's about the slope the the slope of
your trajectory
not about the starting point as both
takes over very very quickly valentin
thank you very very much enjoy your time
in los angeles with cliff stay safe and
stay healthy and thank you for being on
the show
thank you michael thank you for hosting
take care
you